[Musique]
quel est le point commun entre tous ces
visages il s'agit de personnes qui font
du bien notre société sélectionné dans
différents domaines
le département de la réunion organisé
une soirée protocolaire en leur honneur
teva engagement mais avec le sens de
l'humilité le l'engagement souvent
désintéresser des personnes peu connu et
pourtant elle réalise des actions énorme
dans leur domaine c'est une première
pour moi depuis présidents
d'associations et 1994 n'a jamais
reconnu de tel en tant qu'association
donc pour moi c'est important que ce
soit yann reconnaissant donc tout ça que
si la russie ont la famille dans
l'équipe québec et là c'est cette taxe à
l'émotion que j'ai ressentie
le public découvre alors les dix neuf
récipiendaires et souvent ce qui le
valorise entre nice et la famille de son
animal répète il a ses mauvais côtés de
rama yade mon épouse qui m'a soutenu
dans des temps difficiles que j'avais au
niveau de l'entreprise
ce serait pas été possible elle a réussi
à perdre pas grâce à la pac et tradition
française
quand j'ai envie d'aider les personnes
on a fait des engins palais des plaisirs
la route tous les risques dans la vie
d'un reportage un monde accessible un
monde par la plus dans 10 cas parce que
on pourra se déplacer comme tout le
monde on pourra marcher comme tout le
monde dans la rue vous avez entendu
comme moi c'est que il transmet son
savoir ils forment des jeunes au cas où
mc personnes âgées là où une personne
handicapée
non mais attendez pas cru mes filles me
retourne
mais bon comme mal et honorer mon
souhait est bien mais ces deux d'être
moi même d'être patient d'été menteur
tout ce que mais peuvent faire pour les
personnes âgées et handicapées adultes
les familles d'accueil
et si un portrait est à retenir un
portrait exemplaire c'est celui du
président du comité handisport
handicapé par la vie mais tellement vrai
dans son esprit dans le débattement
oumma quand je vois toutes ces personnes
qui donne d'elle-même
ça nous rassure rien n'est perdu il faut
continuer à se battre
la société réunionnaise a besoin de nous
nous vivons sur une berline avec une
belle population est bien de la
générosité il y en a et le département
accompagne toutes ces personnes
généreuses au service des autres quand
vous avez des enfants qui pense oui
il est banni il y avait une oreille au
gardien et nous c'est nous qui l'avons
britons l'année
et le parcours est ce qu on peut
applaudir l'acteur s'il vous plaît